so this is going to be about search and
it's supposed to be a rather general
introduction where did I come from I'm a
physicist by education I have worked a
lot with hypothesis testing both as a
researcher and as a data scientist now
but I have also worked with the
recommendations and the company that
gives me the opportunity to work with
research from time to time is automatic
we are responsible for a range of
products that are all about publishing
and having a an online presence like PI
data we care about open source a lot of
our developers contribute back to the
open source WordPress software and we
are also a very special company in the
sense that each and every single one of
my 550 Plus colleagues works from ever
they want and wherever they want to live
so we are a hundred percent distributed
even so we do meet from time to time so
this is the data division on our recent
meeting in Montreal last month we are
responsible for a range of things even
though we are not that many people so we
do tracking we consult with other teams
we keep our elasticsearch applications
I've been running we do a/b testing we
do a lot of stuff we build applications
on our data and we care about search
because well I forgot to say that so the
most notably we have this platform
called WordPress comm where anyone can
build a website or blog and because of
that we do have a lot of text data that
we would like to make searchable and
discoverable for our users so this top
graph shows the number of posts
published on our sites and this little
animation shows some activity on our on
our platform that includes both posting
but also Commons and other social
interactions and I took that on a Monday
morning in Europe so that's not the
busiest time so we have lots of text
data and our division is actually
responsible for one user facing
application which is the reader and
that's a place where you know our users
can follow sites and they can also
search for sites and get recommendation
so when you search for pi data for
example you've got some some blog posts
about pi data the last one is from one
of my colleagues who gave a talk a few
weeks ago about an anomaly detection
that he wrote so yes so last year we
built the search into the reader but of
course when we do that we have to the
first thing we should ask ourselves like
what do users want when they search and
that will depend on the user so the user
could come to your search application
with different ideas so let's say if
we're talking about a person who is
maybe thinking about going to South
Africa on the next location they might
come and search something like clients
South Africa and that's probably because
they want some information but sometimes
so that would be an informational search
but some time later they might comment
sexual flight Cape Town or a lightweight
tent and that's because they probably
want to buy something or they might want
to make them transactionally they want
to book that slide so we call that
transactional and on a day before
departure they might search for I don't
know Lufthansa web check-in because they
want to check-in but they just can't
find that site so they know exactly
where they want to go but they just
don't know how to find it so like a
search engine like Google serves all of
these cases but if you build your own
maybe you don't need all of them so you
should take a look at your data and if
you have some search application running
and see what I usually use is actually
looking for and we did that with our
data it's a little bit old this plot
which means you might still find like a
Pokemon in there or something like that
but this is a word cloud of searches of
our users performed in our reader and
the bigger the fun the more unique users
searched for this term because we have
some like power users who search a lot
so it's better to just you get unique
users we can see some things in here so
you might see that some of the words are
not complete that's because we want to
search as you type application so they
will if those slow typists they will all
be see some without popping up while
they're typing
and you can see some of the types of
searches that I mentioned on the
previous slide so for example dashboard
would just look somewhere in the middle
is where our users can edit their site
settings so this is a navigational
search they want to go there and didn't
know how to which is not nice but that's
how it is but you also see that most of
these searches that we have are very
broad like people look for very broad
topics and those searches are probably
not even like informational searches
because I assume that our users already
know a thing or two about things like
fashion or travel or books right so
these are probably searches where our
users want to find some afraid in some
inspiration or maybe they are looking
for a community of people with a sit
with similar interests to their own so
what we learned from this is that for
example something like popularity of a
post is probably something that our
users care about more than the actual
information contained in that post but
of course like for polarity is nice and
a lot of search engines will take them
to count somewhere but of course users
weren't more than just popular posts
such as posts that mention or documents
that just mentioned on words of very
searching forms so on this slide I
summarize if you think that users might
expect when they come to a search engine
so of course we all are used to Google
and like very fancy search engines so
that when we search something most of us
will just accept magic so that the thing
magically knows what we are looking for
but there are so a few more actionable
items that we can look at so users want
of course relevant content when I
searched about for Lyon South Africa I
want those words to appear in the text
and most of the traditional like
literature but search engines will will
focus on that but there are other things
that are great which is for example
original content it is always better to
send a user to the original so
them give them a lot of pages that
that's just cite something they we also
tend to put through export content so
it's better to give pages or documents
that are written by someone who knows
those stuff but at the same time it's
also good to return results that I have
some level of clarity so that are
written at a level that the user can
understand and of course you don't know
a lot about if they use it but for
example if I search for giraffe you
would maybe want to return something
different than if I was searching for
the Latin name of some species because
then I'm probably more of an expert in
that field so I would want to have more
like biology type of scientific papers
what more of course new content is also
something that uses like you never want
to send people to sites that are not
trustworthy you don't want to have spam
in your list of results and stuff like
that so that's important and also
diversity is important if for example if
I was searching for introduction to
programming you would not want to return
ten results that are all called
introduction to programming a Python
even if Python is your favorite language
if as long as you don't know much more
about me you would want to return some
mixture of programming and Python
programming in Java whatever and finally
another thing that is important is high
precision so some something that users
tend to do or all people tend to do is
when you give them a list of search
results they try to gauge if that list
is actually good or not before they
trust you before they click on something
so they will not just even if the first
result is top-notch
if the the following three are [ __ ]
users will not trust your search engine
so that's called high precision so you
want a lot of relevant results in the
high up in your in your list of search
results
so yes that's what you want might sound
a little bit overwhelming so but then
let's just look at what what is the
search engine on the high level it's a
thing that connects a user to a document
collection or maybe the whole internet
but under the hood there of course more
things like um if we stick about the
internet you need something that
collects all the data from the internet
so that will be a crawler and that will
insert it into your document collection
in our case that's much easier because
we mostly search the documents that are
produced in our platform so we already
have that so I will not mention the
crawler any longer then you will want to
make these documents searchable and
that's a task that is taken on by the
indexing and the searchable data is
stored in something that's called index
on the far other end you would want
something that interprets what the user
wants so at the very least you'll have
to translate the the terms that the user
types into something that you can feed
into your program but you might also
want to do more so that's called query
builder it produces cuy and then finally
you have the ranker that puts everything
together and gives you the best list of
results that to match your query with
the index of documents that you have and
then we turned up to the user and we
will look at several of these components
in more detail so the first one is
indexing so that's about making
documents searchable in a very fast way
we could have an a document like this
which is very short but is the nice
texture browned off map to black dots so
of course that's easily searchable but
if you imagine you have a lot of
documents and you have someone searching
for Doc you don't want to pause every
document every time that someone
searches so you need to put these into a
different format and a good format for
that is the one on them right so where
you turn you your
your extreme text into a list of terms
that appear in this text and you store
the counts with them so that you can
easily access them and we will have a
few sites that will talk about how you
go from the left to the right of course
most documents have more structure than
this sentence so in reality your your
index will have more fields so to
document could have a title and a body
and you would want to analyze the title
and the body and of course you might
also want to have additional information
that you want to store along with this
data like other features like for
example one voice is post published how
many pages link to this webpage maybe if
you have if your Facebook and you have
likes you probably want to store the
likes along with them with the posts so
yeah how do you get from there from the
left to the right the first step that
you won't have to take yourself course
organization so that's you have to
divide the text into meaningful tokens
most most often those are words could of
your test sentences or engrams and this
task is for some languages it's
relatively easy because they're white
space separated like English or German
for other languages it's more difficult
so I do not speak Chinese but this is
apparently a famous Chinese poem and I
went that through a tokenizer
and it told me that in some cases two of
the characters form a word together so
you cannot just assume that every
character is a word and if someone just
speaks Chinese that can tell me if
that's correct but the tokenizer did
because I couldn't tell but um but even
even if in a language like English where
it's easy it's important to think about
that organizer because even if it's very
good every mistake like you make at this
level will be all over your search
engine and there are some things that
you have to think about so even in
English or German there were some
challenges
for example you will want to decide how
do you treat named entities that consist
of several words do you want to index
that as Empire State Building or as
Empire and state and building if you are
looking at sentences in some way it have
to decide what to do with abbreviations
that come with a dart at the end or even
like abbreviations like us you'd have to
decide if that one term or is that two
terms U and s names dates and times
numbers dates and times come in many
different formats so you might want to
bring them also the same format or not
you might have to think about what you
do with all the the punctuation in these
numbers then of course then in English
you have nice things like sheet she
can't so do you want to so that can't or
is it cannot and then words in a text
can be hyphenated for many reasons so
either it because we are author wanted
that or it's just because the word is at
the end of a line so you also have to
handle that in some way and there is a
very nice blog post on the IBM develop a
lot about that and I guess you can't
read that but I guess like that you can
download the slides and click on the
link if you like so this is I didn't
expect this soon to be that big so the
phone is a little bit small so but this
is just an example where I took a text
from the Wikipedia page about us do you
have the sort of the mascot of our team
or division we like them so we have a
lot of examples with giraffes I took
this text on the Wikipedia page it's not
the best Wikipedia page I've seen but
and I went that 32 different organizers
that are available on Python and in
orange highlighted you see the
differences so they treat this is text
blob and specially they treat
punctuation differently and hyphenated
words so if for example if you would run
a tokenizer like the one from Spacely in
your search engine you'd have a hard
time if your user later on wants to find
even-toed animals because you'd end up
separate
in this word other analysis that you
could do on your text before you store
it in the index is stemming that's
bringing all the the words back to the
root form Lammert ization which is like
turning tools into singular and so on
and maybe removing the most common words
so if you had a sentence like the girls
car are different colors and sizes if
you apply a very strong Seminole
amortization and start with cleaning to
that you just end up with Google car
beautiful color size like that could be
useful if you apply the same to the
University of the universe which is of
course like a place that we would all
love to attend it just have you know
universe universe which is less useful
so in general if you if you look at
these methods you'd have to make a
trade-off between recall and precision
recall is the number of the results that
you can return for a search query so if
you apply this you can you and someone
searches for Kyle you can return many
more results than if you don't do not
but at the same time you lose precision
so if I I want to know about girls cars
and I want them to be flow I have no no
chance to find that if I removed that
information at the next time how do we
implement that do we have to like write
a lot of code for that luckily not so
there are products out there that do a
lot of this indexing and analysis for
you we use elastic search which is a
search engine built on the scene it has
a lot of nice features such as it comes
with a lot of analyzers that you can
just use out of the box and it also has
a nice query DSL to work with we run
several classic search classes with
hundreds of terabytes of data and our
data engineers are really great with
that some of these they support
something like sixty million queries per
day I think and
twelve million index operations per day
we have a lot of use cases not just post
search but also we want recommendations
on elasticsearch related posts a lot of
internal use cases also some some stuff
for our vehicle users so we also have
hosting for like big professional
websites like news websites and they
also have their own elasticsearch
applications and this graph shows that
over time like from beginning of 2014
until today we're running ever more
elastic search queries so a lot of
elastic search queries are automatic so
let's okay so how do we build these
crews the GUI builder has the task to
like take the users input and turn it
into something that the machine can
understand and interpret so at the very
least the number one or query building
is that if you run your queries and
analyzed fields you have to apply the
same analysis to your query that you
apply to this analyzed field so if you
stand all the words in your index you
have to stem all the words in a query as
well so we'll look at an example for
this so this is similar to what we do so
it's assumed we have a user who is
searching for dancing unicorns on
rainbows which is probably something
that gives them a lot of very colorful
very nice pictures but they were kind of
slow so we only have this token them so
the first thing we do is to tokenize
that so we divide it into its individual
words but we also keep the full string
so that we can also search for an exact
match we do remove very frequent words
so beyond would probably go away we
apply a rather light stemming not the
hard one that I showed on the page on
the site before so we'd have to apply
that to to all the words so in our case
that would turn the unicorns to just
Unicron and then we have to apply for
search as you tie
which means that we do not want to look
only for rainbow but we want to look for
everything that starts like that luckily
we don't have to do all of these
ourselves the first one the first three
steps come automatically in
elasticsearch so we don't have to worry
about that and as nice and as I
mentioned we only apply a red light
stemming so if you go like to to our
search and you search for traveling and
for travel you will get different
results and Google also behaves in a
similar way but they have enabled like
they have way more data and way more
resources so in their case the
distinction is is way bigger than in our
case so let's look at what an elastic
search query looks like so this is an
example of an index with just of
inserting just four documents into an
index
it's from the r6 search documentation so
they use this nice example about the Fox
and stuff that everyone uses so we have
the first element is the quick brown fox
the second is the quick brown fox jumps
over the lazy dog and the quick brown
fox jumps over the quick dark and brown
fox brown dog night nice poetry so an
elastic search grid to to match a word
with these fields would look just as
simple as that so in the the the index
has the titles of all these documents
and you just say like we want to have
the worked quick in that document and
with like I am sort of popular ranking
we tell you that the first document is
the most relevant for this query because
it does contain the word quick and it's
also short so the the fourth one would
not be relevant at all and the others
are sort of in between so that best of
course is just like a very simple query
but elastic search has
way more stuff to offer than this so you
can like combine different ways to
search across different fields you can
apply it when waiting to different
fields you can use function scores to
achieve whatever you want and you can
also use aggregations to kind of
summarize your data so I'll show you the
query that one of my colleagues used
which combined where she wanted to find
like higher level information in our
data so she combined several book
queries so and there is the option to
say like my documents have to contain I
have to fulfill a certain condition
that's the must in the bull query so she
said I want to have posts from the
beginning of the year and then she and
she combined several trees in a must and
I should so that says it's better if it
matches but it's okay if it doesn't the
minimum number should match because one
says that not every not every condition
has to be fulfilled but at least one has
to so she she looked for posted her
either in their title or in their tags
or in their body the words new and
resolution because she wanted to study
post about New Year's resolutions and
then she applied an aggregation by by
the date and she got the data got data
from which she could directly make this
plot which compares like when do people
post about New Year's resolutions to
when do they post about dogs and you
know people post about dogs all the time
but they only post about New Year's
resolution at the beginning of the year
a COO builder can write queries like
that but they can also construct way
more complicated stuff so here's sort of
an overview of what else cupola could do
for you so you could make it guess which
language to search in which would be
pretty nice because people don't um
don't often have their browser language
set to the language they surgeons so we
happen to find that it could find and
correct spelling mistakes as painful for
users if they have spelling mistake
they don't come up with a single search
results they couldn't mind similar
searches so that they can suggest better
search term you all know that from
Google they could expand the queries to
find more and better results so that's
for example I the question if I go and I
search for eat you and ma maybe if I
have post about food and boomer this
would also be relevant but the user to
tell me that so I could expand the couid
you also take related terms into account
and we could pull in features for
personalization so can be arbitrarily
complicated if you like then the final
component of the search engine that we
want to talk about is the ranking so you
have the query you have the index you
have to put them together and find out
which documents are the best the most
native approach is of course to just
look for the words that are in the query
and count them in your posts so you
could show just by frequency which is
not that great so the first thing people
came up with is instead of going with
frequency you could go with the
frequency or a function of the frequency
of the term in the document but you
normalize it through the terms frequency
in your whole collection so that means
if I search for I say vgf I would just
approach that very naively I could end
up giving the same word two way to the
and to the juror and tudjarov while
documents that contain giraffe will be
way more relevant to my user with that
search query so yeah so that's tf-idf
like the most basic ranking function
ever just the word frequency divided by
the its frequency in the document
collection but it's not so great because
with a function like that you still have
a lot of you elleven still increases a
lot when a you
the uses the same term over and over
again so this could work if you were
working with like scientific papers
where people have strong have like
strong guidelines well the way how you
write this text but if you have users
who like to some SEO and stuff tf-idf
isn't TDI FS not great so there people
have come up with different ranking
functions one of them is PM 25 which is
a family of ranking function that is
actually just a modification of tf-idf
that has two parameters K and P and it
sort of regularizes tf-idf so that
doesn't grow that much when you repeat a
word a lot of times so it still has the
property that the more more often you
have a void in a document the higher the
score and still if the term is not very
frequent and collecting the whole
collection it also gets a high school
but there is a penalty for like having
very long documents so if you just
repeat the same word over and over again
it doesn't give you that for it and
compared to tf-idf it skate doesn't
scale as much with a number of times
that a user repeats a word so in this
part I compare a version of tf-idf to
its modification and be m25 and it's a
for a document of 500 words and it's
some shown as the number of times that I
repeat some term in the document so if n
is 0 the term it does not appear in the
document if it's 5 finally it's a
document that's just 500 times the same
word and the y-axis is the score at this
number of times that the document that
the term appears in a doesn't normalized
to the score to when it appears only one
time and you see that tf-idf still goes
rather quickly while be m25 is is more
behaved and sort of levels out so you
don't gain if you keep repeating the
same word so that's like two of the most
well-known functions just for a relative
relevancy waiting but of course then
there is
um there are other features especially
when you look at the Internet so and of
course what does the internet have it
has links so then there is the famous
PageRank algorithm which does not drink
documents necessarily by their relevance
but first of all by their importance so
it does a link analysis and the idea is
behind that is that the more important
documents have more incoming links than
the less important ones and if if a very
important document links to my document
then my document is also more important
so if you imagine that all these squares
are documents be to one to nine and this
is sort of a graph of a small section of
the Internet you see that like for
example a random walk over all these
links would lead you to d3 many times
but never to d9 so the page showing of a
page is calculated as some constant with
the parameter D plus a weighted sum of
all these incoming links and as some
depends on the page rank of the pages
that link to my document divided by the
number of outgoing links that they have
so even if like a pages space PageRank
is great if it just links everywhere
it also doesn't count that much so you
see this is some because it's the page
rank appears on both side of the
equation so it's a it's a recursive
algorithm so this is nice and cool as
the famous paper and stuff the downside
of this is of course that people know
about this and they you know hates try
to get around it so this is of course
very very vulnerable to to link forming
but you can do stuff with this and you
can also make modifications of it so for
example two types of pages that users
like to see a lot in in search results
are called hubs and authorities so a hub
would be a page that collects good in
from good sites so good
links to about a certain topic so maybe
I know about something and then I just
collect all the good articles about that
on my page so that's a helpful page for
user and an authority is a patient is
written by an author that Huli knows
about the self so if you have start with
the hypothesis that good hearts linked
to good authorities and vice versa you
can you can use a similar algorithm as
for PageRank to identify these pages of
course you'll have far less data so this
is more vulnerable to to a problem so
you can run one off we run into because
of too little data yeah now that you we
have like you I have looked at ranking
and architecture and stuff like that
let's look at one thing that data
scientists might tend to overlook which
is the presentation so when you have a
search engine and it's user facing it's
super important to have good designers
and front-end developers who make it
really nice because it's from our
experience like sometimes we we tweak
the algorithm and it doesn't change as
much as a simple design change could
make so because and that's because users
want to trust your search and they they
are sort of looking for information to
validate this is this search works so
things like thinking about the the
length of the abstract is important it's
important to think about like which
extra information do you want to show
them so for example we show likes and
comments which are sort of like a social
validation that this is a good content
or we show extra tags which also seems
to work very nicely which gives them
more context so this can have a big
impact on having a good designer on your
team for search engine is it's really
great so I'll skip this I have a list in
tiny fund with the recommended sources
and reading so we might find it and then
lastly I'm a small plug for our blogs
it's called data blog and we write a lot
of stuff there
thank you for listening hello at the
beginning of your presentation you had a
slide with a word count with a word
cloud could you could you switch back to
that some of those very first slides yes
in terms of in terms of page rank what
do you think of this upper right corner
arm word HTTP this is it week and the
page rank went wild I mean no one is
interested in HTTPS no no one is
interested in that that's because not
all of our users understand the search
engine that we provide to them so that's
most likely I think a user it could be
to two things it could be a user who is
trying to navigate to a specific page
and because we have such as you type
then maybe you know when they when I
they're done with the HTTP and they try
to look for for the colon and the
slashes and they're a little bit slow so
we give them without for that and the
other thing is I think I made this plot
very shortly after we introduced HTTPS
for all our sites so maybe they were
actually interested in that at that time
we don't probably a combination of both
I thanks for the talk a question about
the stemming versus lament ization
question one is do you know any I think
all of what you were telling about was
about elasticsearch are there any
built-in tools for limit ization and
from your experience is does it give any
advantage in the in terms of relevance
or precision if you do limit ization
versus stemming
if I didn't catch one you apply so when
you're processing your you're like when
you're creating the index and you
instead of stemming you slamet ization
does it improve your results or is it
sufficient to just end the words so in
our case what we found is that it hurts
us if we apply these methods too rigidly
and I think one of my colleagues is with
like a whole very long post about this
so you could probably tell you more but
and and even more than in English I
think it's hurtful in some other
languages so we usually apply a little
bit of both but very very lightly
hello how do you measure the quality of
your search so in general there are
different ways for us we we know that
there is a big variety of the quality or
like the engagement of our search
results depending on the search term
because for some sessions we have a lot
of data and for some just not and some
also like much more difficult to treat
than others
so in general we have to limit ourselves
so for something that we can run on all
search terms we have to limit ourselves
through either simple metrics so we
mostly look at the at the rate of some
sort of interaction with the first ten
search results and depending on what we
want this could either be if the user
clicks on that but we also want to
engage our users so it would be creative
if the content we showed was not just
like did not just have like a click by
title that they click on but we also
want them to like a comment or follow
the site so we will often like look at
something like interactions with the
first number of results but that's
mostly because we cannot do much more
than that
for most systems we could do more for
like travel or fashion than we could
really minor search last but we don't
get so we don't have more time for a
question now so you can probably ask her
directly sir Thank You Siri in for you
Tom
[Applause]